hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play mayor Meyer my
LA when lights die okay so this is a
game that was recommended to me by
another youtuber and I'm going to find
out what it's all about because I really
don't know play WASD and look skip and
real wear headphones turn lights out or
play with oculus rift I do not have that
but uh you know that would be very
interesting to play a horror game with
the oculus rift that would be that would
be so amazing I mean you wouldn't be
able to see me you'd see me like have
this here and hope recording it would be
hard but it might be interesting you
never know okay so let's go bone
explosives on Funko mostly when it's
outside it's a beautiful fish and Swapan
who keep the Lybian to Kumasi automata
usually as a machine on the left here
partially do nikuman click t over 2 is
explicably so to know to resume the
twerkus kunoichi virtually reject more
year that activity ceremony
home kiss can you phone there was a
q-tip fell but a good well that wasn't a
good thing I'm not sure exactly what
happened to there but the gist of it is
I'm in a virtual reality world and I've
got something tied directly to my
cerebral processes and this game is in
french but with english subtitles so I
was speaking French no I'm allowed that
would be disrespectful okay this looks
bad I don't wanna are you real
stop being a baby okay doors that don't
open so I'm gonna assume most of these
unless they're explicitly opened I'm not
gonna go in here okay so there are
pictures of a girls school group back a
long time ago some scientists there
obviously someone is in this program
that is not supposed to okay mal now V
therefore they're okay their controller
of an newly fertile legend Emma
maintainin let the test wah fever lucky
there's technologies revolute on Holly's
yellow I can't repeat French okay I'll
try my best but there's a bloody knife
here that I can't pick up uh everyone
ignore the fact that I tried to read
French there hey wait a minute
I know that painting that was just
analysis I was just looking at that like
ten minutes ago
all right anyway
all right let's see what's going on here
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
are you still back there
what are you huh that was a trick that
was a trick see trick hi hi there hello
little girl
go away Jesus oh hi hi hi hi hi
everybody calm down for two seconds here
everybody just calm down there's
something weird about this dream yeah no
kidding
oh okay there's another hallway here I
can go down oh you little girl don't
like you let me out please
oh I don't like you where do you go oh
really
all right
oh man I've another scare like that no
long last time oh man okay let's get it
together and let's move forward is he
still there he better not still be there
that son of a [ __ ] oh man so wrong oh I
got a headache okay here we go
all right powering through can't stop
now I'm too awesome to be stopped by
whatever shadow demon that was hello
don't mess with me clock cop on the edge
I'm a guy in virtual reality on the edge
I don't want to mess with you you this
looks like don't be breezy don't be
breathing heavy I know you're tricked hi
I know your tricks you can't mess with
the likes of me at least reality seems
to have stopped warping on me oh no it's
another dead end okay no it's not okay
where am I now where am I now
I think I'm headed back towards the
chair but I'm not sure I kind of got
turned around after I ran away screaming
for my life another dead end
hi what's wrong with you little girl you
get away from here you get away you get
away right now you're fine
what is that what is
what is that what is that little girl
you're still creeping me out but at
least you're not a threat again not
again naughty boy
the monster NER limata near I don't know
what I was doing wrong oh man let's try
that again
okay I'll try that again so apparently
oh no I don't know I don't even know I
don't even begin to know I was trying to
get back to the chair but I think that
like it was down this hallway with this
painting and I saw it again but the door
was locked
so whenever she goes
[Applause]
okay I will do that I'll go back to the
chair
oh no oh okay all right so the objective
is to get to the frickin chair without
Oh No I'm not sure if these hallways are
randomly generated I think they are this
game is incredible but they do not like
it okay I'm gonna look no this is just a
big circle that was a big circle okay
don't go down there
avoid the Montaner that launched in here
shut up I don't want to mess with you or
anyone else I want to get to the chair
and go home I bet it won't let me go
home if I do but
shut up they launched in air they
launched in air Oh nose is a dead end
oh good good all right where am I now
it's like it warps me to random places
that I have no idea or or I'm just going
in circles
one or the other I'm not sure which what
is that what's that is that something is
that something down there is that
something I can barely see it but is
that some hey that painting looks
familiar
oh I'm going in the same circle I've
been before I don't want to run into
labels severe I don't like Lee monster
here that's probably not even the words
they're saying in fact that's definitely
yeah really is there I know this excuse
me little girl thank you for the warning
I'm beginning to think that you're on my
side and I don't want to mess with that
guy because right behind me and if I
look at him he's gonna be a limit in
here
good girl when do you move flip while no
you're creepy but at least you're
non-lethal oh man Lee montaner blame on
stinner blame on Stan air blame Austin
air I see something at the end of that
hallway what's that
that looks good wait no have I seen that
before that leads to the doctor's chair
oh crap it's not randomly generated I've
already been here but there wasn't a
chair back here was there let me just
double-check make sure I didn't miss
anything like down side hallway with a
door open or something
dead end isn't it it's a dead end
it's a dead end where'd you go little
girl you read behind me good good you
stay close to me
okay so where have I been before I think
I've I turn left down this hallway
that's where the monster first appeared
so maybe he's blocking my way to the
exit maybe I don't know maybe okay
was that a Saleh I'm on Jer
I mean chair where's blame on cetera
which way which way which way which way
which way wait I say you you're coming
from that way Lee motion yeah I know you
I know you I know you what is this
what the hell no weird oh you know get
away get away get away get away get away
get away get away get away get away I
don't like this game I don't like it
you're weird
you're freaking weird you're all weird
you're weird okay I got to go down the
way that the limo Austin air was going
like I hear you
Oh things changed what way well oh no
maybe things do change wait wait a
minute that's all right parla this is
different you're messing with me you're
messing with me your measurement you're
messing with me
okaywe no you're not you just let me out
of a different exit I need to go this
way again
so the monster came from down this left
hallway yes was that whoa hello what's
going on what's going on this is new
looks like a kid's room
hi there was a lot of experimentation on
kids hello are you nice
that was wrong
Oh Sora oh no oh no oh no little girl
are you gonna tell me what's going on in
this place
no thank you I don't want anything to do
with you I don't want anything to do
with you at all ever ever like ever this
whole thing is so creepy
it's so creepy I can't even begin to
wrap my head around it it's so damn
creepy oh I can't deal with this I can't
deal with this I can't take it
my head is like what is this this the
same way I went before your door just
decided to open now I don't know can I
hear a little girl oh it's a dead end
damn it that's great I'm not going back
that way because I think it back tracks
maybe I'm gonna go down this hallway to
the there's got to be in there
the most in here my Monson air is down
that hallway I'm gonna get him to come
this way so I can lead them in a circle
because obviously I need to go where
lame Austin Aries are you are you coming
you come buddy I see you I see you I see
you I see your way down that hallway but
I see you I know I know
I know he's right there let's go through
here and see where this leads
[Music]
I don't know if like I should trust the
little kid
give me get me get me get me out of here
get me out here sit entertain the
transfer No
no no no I see you know you let me out
of here you let me out of here
don't don't even don't even do anything
you stay right there
[Music]
good it's done I think I was amazing and
horrible that was incredible antara oh
my god everyone should play that or no
one oh I don't know why actually I was
like it was like the perfect combination
of uh of what I love in a horror game I
mean for one it was Holly him like the
atmosphere was spot and it was amazing I
kept I felt lost and confused which is
like step one of creating an atmosphere
of fear and then there was this constant
little girl behind me constantly she
wasn't doing anything I think she was
helping me but she was still always
there then the monster just stock in
hallways there was no collection
mechanic it was just pure and simple get
out of there and it wouldn't even let me
out I knew it wasn't gonna let me out I
knew it
step one of 64 you shut up [ __ ] oh god
okay anyway so that was awesome and it's
totally free so look at the link in the
description below even the website that
it came from is like really amazing it's
really well made website so check it out
for yourselves oh man that was
so thank you guys so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that i've done and as always I will see
you in the next video bye
nice print which is